♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE'VE SEEN ALL DAY
THE DESPICABLE THREATS AGAINST
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS.
THIS IS VERY DANGEROUS.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND
SECURE.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CONDEMNED BY
ALL AMERICANS, IF THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
DONALD TRUMP JR. TWEETING AS
SOMEONE'S FAMILY WHOSE STOMACH
HAS BEEN DIRECTLY AFFECTED, I
CONDEMN WHOEVER DID THIS
REGARDLESS OF PARTY OR IDEOLOGY.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
I HOPE THEY END UP IN JAIL FOR A
LONG TIME.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION, THE
SON OF THE PRESIDENT, ERIC TRUMP
IS WITH US.
IT REALLY DOES BRING INTO FOCUS
MADONNA, I DREAM AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT BLOWING UP THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IT REALLY DOES BRING INTO FOCUS
THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID
ABOUT YOU, ABOUT YOUR ENTIRE
FAMILY, A SEVERED HEAD OF YOUR
FATHER.
LISTEN, YOUR FATHER IS
OUTSPOKEN, ICONOCLASTIC AND HE
FIGHTS FOR WHAT HE WANTS AND HE
SHAKES PEOPLE UP.
VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT MAXINE
WATERS HAS BEEN DOING OR THE
MONTH-LONG GETTING IN PEOPLE'S
FACES AND CONFRONTATIONS WITH
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN ERIC HOLDER.
I THOUGHT YOUR OPENING MONOLOGUE
WAS BEAUTIFUL.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD BE HUNTED
DOWN AND HE SHOULD BE THROWN IN
JAIL FOR A VERY, VERY LONG TIME.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHICH PARTY IT
IS.
LAST YEAR I HAD WHITE POWDER
SENT TO MY HELP.
DON HAD WHITE POWDERS INTO HIS
HOUSE.
THE WHITE POWDER LITERALLY BLEW
UP IN MY WIFE'S FACE AND THE FBI
AND THE SECRET SERVICE, THEY
CAUGHT THE GUY AND THEY THREW
HIM IN JAIL.
THEY NEED TO DO THE EXACT SAME
THING TO THIS PERSON.
THEY NEED TO HUNT THIS PERSON
DOWN, THEY NEED TO THROW THE
PERSON IN JAIL, AND THEY NEED TO
THROW AWAY THE KEY BECAUSE
HONESTLY THE LACK OF CIVILITY IS
UNREAL.
THIS ISN'T THE COUNTRY WE ARE,
THIS ISN'T WHO WE ARE.
THERE ARE MANY DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE ALL GREAT
PEOPLE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE
GREAT PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T WANT THIS NONSENSE.
THIS ISN'T RIGHT.
>> Sean: I'VE WATCHED THE
HORRIBLE THINGS SAID ABOUT YOUR
SISTER.
I'VE WATCHED WHAT YOUR YOUNGER
BROTHER BARRON HAS HAD TO GO
THROUGH.
I WATCHED THE MOST VILE THINGS
SAID ABOUT MELANIA, WHO WAS A
WONDERFUL WOMAN, I'VE GOTTEN TO
KNOW HER PERSONALLY.
FORGET ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S IN THE ARENA.
IT LIKE YOU HAD WHITE POWDER
SENT TO ME AND OTHER THREATS FAR
WORSE THAN THAT.
AND I REALLY SYMPATHIZE WITH
WHAT THESE PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING THROUGH
TODAY BECAUSE I'VE BEEN THERE,
BUT THE REALITY IS MOST OF THEM
HAVE BEEN SILENT WITH MAXINE
WATERS IN THE LEAD UP TO THIS
AND PAM BONDI, SECRETARY
NIELSEN, SARAH SANDERS, TED CRUZ
AND HIS WIFE.
HENRY KISSINGER.
MITCH McCONNELL, FOUR
INSTANCES FOR HIM.
KEVIN McCARTHY HAVING A
BOULDER THROWN THROUGH HIS
OFFICE WINDOW.
THEY'VE BEEN VIRTUALLY SILENT ON
HIS INSTANCES.
>> NOT TO MENTION PICKUP TRUCKS
THAT ARE BEING TORCHED IN
PARKING LOTS AT RALLIES AND SO
MANY OTHER THINGS.
HOW HARD IS IT JUST TO SAY THAT
THIS IS NOT RIGHT?
THAT EVERYBODY CONDEMNS THIS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT POLITICAL
SIDE YOU'RE ON?
EVERYBODY CONDEMNS IT AND THESE
PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE IN JAIL FOR
A VERY LONG TIME AND THIS
DOESN'T REPRESENT THE POLITICAL
PARTY.
HOW HARD IS THAT TO SAY?
YOU SEE SOME OF THE KIND OF
DIATRIBES THE CNN WENT ON TODAY
AND SOME OF THE OTHER NEWS
NETWORKS WENT ON TODAY AND THEY
JUST FURTHER DEEPEN THE DIVIDE
THAT THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THEY ARE SO UPSET
THAT YOUR DAD, I BELIEVE
RIGHTFULLY, CALLS OUT FAKE NEWS.
WE HAVE WATCHED THROUGH THE
YEARS COME BEYOND TWO YEARS IF
YOU TAKE THE ELECTION INTO
ACCOUNT THAT EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY
THEY JUST TRASH YOUR FATHER, SAY
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO SAY AND
THEN WHEN THEY GET CALLED OUT --
FOR EXAMPLE THEY ALWAYS GIVE
HILLARY A PASS.
THEY GAVE OBAMA A PASS.
THEY ARE ATTACKING YOUR FATHER
WITH CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
LIES ABOUT RUSSIAN FOR TWO YEARS
AND THEY ARE WRONG.
YOUR DAD CALLS THEM OUT FOR
BEING FAKE AND THEY ARE AND
SOMEHOW THEY'RE GOING TO EQUATE
THAT TO A CALL FOR VIOLENCE?
THAT IS TOTAL B.S. AND DAVE GOT
TO KNOW THAT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE ALL FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT UNTIL YOU SAY
SOMETHING THAT THEY DISAGREE
WITH AND THEN THERE ARE NO
LONGER FOR THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT'S WHY TWITTER COMMITS WHY
SOCIAL, IT'S WHY THESE
RALLIES -- I WAS IN HOUSTON, MY
FATHER 22,000 PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE AND 50,000 PEOPLE
OUTSIDE.
IT'S WHY IT'S BEEN SUCH A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR HIM, BECAUSE
HE CAN TALK TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND CUT THROUGH THE
NONSENSE.
ABOUT THE MEDIA.
YOU KNOW THIS BETTER THAN ANY
HUMAN BEING IN THE WORLD,
CONTROLLED BY A VERY SMALL GROUP
OF ELITISTS.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIM, THEY DON'T
LIKE HIS MESSAGE.
THEY GOT IT WRONG.
THEY DIDN'T THINK HE COULD WIN.
IN TERMS OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
THEY GIVE HIM A 1.9% CHANCE OF
WINNING THAT ELECTION DAY AND
NOW THEY'RE DOUBLING DOWN AND
THEY'RE DOUBLING DOWN AGAIN AND
IF THAT HYPOCRISY.
THEY DON'T WANT MY FATHER TO BE
RIGHT.
THEY WANT TO DO ANYTHING THEY
CAN TO USE ANYTHING AGAINST MY
FATHER AND I SAY THIS ALL THE
TIME, THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY GOING
TO GET IT WRONG AGAIN.
>> Sean: WHAT YOUR TAKE ON THE
MIDTERM?
>> IT'S A HARDER READ IN THE
HOUSE.
I DO BELIEVE EVERYTHING IS IN
PLAY AND IT'S ALL ABOUT TURNOUT.
>> IF THE ARMY OF TRUMP GETS OUT
THERE WE WILL WIN.
IF PEOPLE ARE COMPLACENT AND
THEY STAY AT HOME I DON'T THINK
WE WILL.
IF THE ARMY OF TRUMP HAS TO GET
OUT AND I HEAR ALL THE TIME MY
GUY IS NOT THE BALLOT.
I GO YOU CAN'T THINK THAT WAY,
YOU HAVE TO GET OUT, YOU HAVE TO
VOTE.
IF YOU ARE NOT VOTING REPUBLICAN
YOU ARE EFFECTIVELY VOTING
AGAINST MY FATHER AND YOU HAVE
TO GET OUT.
THE COUNTRY IS DOING SO WELL,
OUR ECONOMY IS DOING WELL.
>> Sean: WE KNOW WITH THE
PELOSI AGENDA IS.
THEY WANT TO KEEP OBAMACARE,
THEY WANT THEIR CRUMBS BACK.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
>> THEY WANT TO DOUBLE YOUR
TAXES AND THEY WANT TO FIGHT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ABOLISH ICE
AND THEY WANT TO DO SO MANY
OTHER THINGS.
THIS COUNTRY IS ON FIRE.
IT'S DOING SO WELL AND WE HAVE
TO KEEP REPUBLICANS IN POWER.
>> Sean: IT'S A WEIRD POSITION
TO BE IN THAT THEY ALMOST HAVE
TO CHEER FOR AMERICA TO DO AS
BAD AS WE DID IN THE OBAMA YEARS
SO THEY CAN GET THEIR POWER BACK
AND IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE HAS
HAPPENED.
TWO YEARS OF AMAZING PROSPERITY.
WHAT I'M ARGUING IS IF YOU VOTE
FOR ANY DEMOCRAT IN ANY DISTRICT
IN THE HOUSE, YOU ARE VOTING FOR
PELOSI.
YOU DON'T SHOW UP, THAT'S A HALF
A VOTE FOR PELOSI AND IF YOU
VOTE FOR ANY DEMOCRATIC SENATOR
YOU MIGHT AS WELL VOTE FOR
CHUCK SCHUMER BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING.
>> THAT'S 100% RIGHT.
THEY WOULD RATHER SEE AMERICA
FAIL THAN MY FATHER SUCCEED.
I'VE SAID THAT FOR YEARS.
THEY WOULD RATHER SEE AMERICA
FAIL THAN MY FATHER SUCCEED.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO GET OUT
THERE, YOU HAVE TO VOTE AND YOU